[Music]
on this Thursday night an Ontario Police
Sergeant ambushed and killed the latest
Canadian officer to be murdered in the
line of duty he's described by his
colleagues there's a coach a mentor
someone that everybody looked up to
new rules for migrants at the U.S Mexico
border they are not
dangerous people they have been in
danger the potential consequences once
time's up for title 42.
insuring athlete safety the fed's new
measures aimed at stopping abuse and
misconduct in sports
global national with Donna Friesen
reporting tonight
we're here this afternoon to share some
details with you of the tragic loss of
one of our officers who is yet again
been murdered simply selflessly serving
his community
it's another devastating loss for
Canada's First Responders overnight
Ontario Provincial Police Sergeant Eric
Mueller was one of three officers
ambushed while on a call in burjet about
50 kilometers east of Ottawa all three
were shot Mueller did not survive good
evening thanks for joining us Sergeant
Eric Mueller was a respected member of
the opp he's being remembered as a
father a coach and a model police
officer as tariya isri reports in our
top story tonight the town is in shock
a veteran police officer arrived on this
Rural Road not knowing it would be his
last day on the job Sergeant Eric
Mueller and his two colleagues responded
to a call after someone reported hearing
gunshots in the early morning we got the
call just after two they were there
before 2 30
and then they went radio radio silent
and they had called for backup when the
officers got there they walked into an
ambush I heard three three bangs that
sounded like gunshots and I wasn't sure
but then 20 minutes later everything lit
up with sirens and cops 42 year old
Mueller died from his injuries the other
two officers were sent to hospital today
our hearts are broken Ontario Provincial
Police Commissioner Thomas Carrick
remembered Mueller as a family man and a
model officer who spent half his life in
uniform he's described by his colleagues
as a coach a mentor someone that
everybody looked up to the glue that
held his shift together are the best
leader that many people ever had the
privilege of working for 39 year old
Alain belfoy was arrested and charged
with one count of first-degree murder
and two counts of attempted murder using
a firearm in this small community of
roughly 1100 people there is disbelief
it's really scary to hear that there was
a cop who was shot and killed I'm just
Doors Down from where we live we live
here with our six-month-old baby we
thought it was a fairly safe community
community members are deeply unsettled
by the shooting and at the number of
Canadian police officers who have been
killed or injured on the job over the
last few months Mueller is the fifth
police officer killed in the line of
duty since September in Ontario alone
it's a dangerous job people know that
when they sign up but it shouldn't be
like this prime minister Justin Trudeau
agrees something needs to change I've
been working with the minister of Public
Safety and with the minister of Justice
to see what more we can do to keep them
safe but this has to stop Mueller
experienced the dangers of policing
before in 2008 he was seriously injured
while making an arrest he returned to
work while still recovering colleagues
say his commitment to the job did not
waver a highly respected officer
murdered while serving his community
teria is read Global News burjet Ontario
Sergeant Eric Mueller is the ninth
Canadian police officer to be killed on
the job since last summer in March
Quebec Sergeant Maureen bro was stabbed
while making an arrest a week and a half
before that Edmonton Constable's Travis
Jordan and Brett Ryan were shot while
responding to a family dispute in
December Constable Greg piercalla was
fatally shot in an ambush in Ontario
Constable shailen Yang died in October
in BC after being stabbed while
assisting a Parks officer to issue an
eviction notice Constable's Devin
Northrup and Morgan Russell were also
killed in October responding to a
disturbance at an Ontario home and
Constable Andrew Hong was on a break
from training when he was shot and
killed in an ambush attack in Ontario in
September
two Alberta's Wildfire crisis now where
Canadian soldiers are moving out to help
battle the fires today the Canadian
Armed Forces began deploying Personnel
to establish bases of operations
throughout the province they'll assist
with evacuating communities transporting
resources and aiding firefighters their
efforts will be focused on the areas of
Grand Prairie Fox Creek and Drayton
Valley
the Canadian Armed Forces have now been
are now deploying resources to provide
strategic airlift services and and
construction Engineering Services and
and frankly when these types of tragic
events occur in any Community it's all
hands on deck and we all work together
to make sure that we get the job done
thousands remain displaced by dozens of
active wildfires still burning across
Alberta more than 20 of those blazes are
out of control
in the U.S tens of thousands of migrants
are expected at the country's Southern
border as a pandemic era policy known as
title 42 expires at midnight many
migrants believe they'll have an easier
time claiming asylum in the U.S and have
been rushing across the border to beat
the deadline but as Jackson prosco
reports the Biden Administration is
pushing through a sweeping new policy to
again turn Asylum Seekers away
Crush of humanity has gathered at the
U.S Mexico border
people who fled their home countries
came believing they'll soon be able to
enter the U.S
what we hear about immigration is that
it's until May 11th that's why we are
arriving here today says this Colombian
woman who crossed into Arizona in the
middle of the night
tens of thousands of people are awaiting
the expiration of title 42. the pandemic
era policy that bans Asylum Seekers
they've spent days under the hot sun
with little food or water hoping to make
it to the U.S when title 42 expires at
midnight thousands of people per day are
expected to attempt to cross the Biden
Administration has told them to rethink
their plans our borders are not open
people who cross our border unlawfully
and without a legal basis to remain will
be promptly processed and removed at
midnight the U.S will begin a new policy
that requires migrants to First claim
asylum in Mexico the U.S will Deport
anyone who is ineligible and ban them
from re-entering for at least five years
the challenge of course with the Asylum
claims is that even under the new rule
there are still some procedural steps
that DHS has to take before they can
execute the removal of that individual
but coming weeks we'll likely see
processing centers overwhelmed the U.S
has sent soldiers thousands of
immigration officers and legal officials
to the southern border
Emergency Shelters have opened in border
cities where there's been a surge in
people crossing illegally these people's
lives have been in danger they've been
under political oppression they are not
dangerous people they have been in
danger but in the U.S they will no
longer find safety but people who've
made this treacherous Journey for a
better life now risk being deported back
to the countries they fled
Jackson prosco Global News Washington
the Canadian military's independent
sexual misconduct support and Resource
Center is creating a new fund to help
victims pay for Legal Services it's one
of the changes announced today by
defense minister Anita Anand who says
building a strong military is her first
priority
what that means is modernizing our
thinking to ensure that discrimination
sexual harassment
and inequality have absolutely no place
in the Canadian Armed Forces
our Ottawa bureau chief Mercedes
Stevenson joins us now Mercedes honored
announced a handful of changes today how
significant are they
uh Nathan there's no question that these
changes will benefit the men and women
of the Canadian Armed Forces and their
families but they are in many ways the
lowest hanging fruit for the government
to solve there remains really
significant obstacles to change and a
lack of information and updates on how
the Canadian Armed Forces are
progressing on some of those big picture
items for example the transfer of
criminal sexual cases from the military
police system to the civilian police
system and the civilian justice system
we have not received an update on how
many cases have been successfully
transferred and there was a lot of
friction with civilian police forces and
civilian Crown prosecutors saying look
we don't know the military system we are
already at capacity how are we possibly
going to take these cases on but they
have to because former Supreme Court
Justice Louise Arbor has said the
military should not be handling those
cases today Anita Anand said the opp has
been working with the military police at
the Ontario Provincial Police to figure
out a framework for transfers they've
also been working with the RCMP and
other civilian police forces but there
is still no information on how exactly
that is progressing and the other big
one we haven't heard about nisu is the
external monitor that was necessary
former Supreme Court Justice Louise
Arbor said to update Canadians in the
military on sexual misconduct changes
because DND does not tend to be very
responsive she was appointed back in
October of 2022 but in May of 2023 we
still don't have a single update
important perspective there all right
Mercedes Stevenson in Ottawa tonight
thanks Mercedes
Canada's Sports Minister unveiled a
slate of reforms to address reports of
abuse and an ingrained toxic culture in
the nation's Sports system Pascal
Santosh says it's an effort to make
National Sports organizations more
accountable for the funding they receive
Mike drolet reports on the proposed
changes and why some say it still falls
short
if the Canadian sports landscape is at a
Crossroads MP and former Olympian Adam
vancouverton believes a slate of new
reforms will put it back on track what a
huge step forward this is this is
actually Monumental how impactful the
new rules will be to ensure children are
safe remains to be seen but some of the
measures announced include the creation
of a public registry for sanctioned
individuals the Restriction of
non-disclosure agreements making
financial statements public and putting
more athletes on boards non-compliance
says administer Pascal Santos will
result in a loss of funding we will use
this as a lever for change Saint orange
was thrust into the national crisis
almost immediately after becoming Sports
Minister Hockey Canada faced allegations
of misusing funds to pay off sexual
assault victims that Scandal led to
stories of abuse and a harassment in
other sports and ultimately months of
emotional testimony I helped make some
of the policies that Jim can and
apparent and it was totally overwhelming
yeah and I live with the guilt every day
that I let my daughter try that sport
many of those testimonials included
calls for a national inquiry which sent
ownership continues to resist that's
left a sour taste in the mouths of
groups advocating for athletes Global
athletes Rob Kohler for One Believes an
inquiry would lead to the creation of an
independent body overseeing all sport in
Canada right now sport is
self-regulating this is a human rights
crisis happening across Canada happening
in sport no longer can sport
self-regulate there's too many conflicts
of interest there's too many people
wearing the different hats and different
organizations and it's Rift with people
trying to protect each other Hockey
Canada he points out tried to fix itself
and failed will these reforms address
the power imbalance in sport
there's a lot riding on it microwave
Global News Toronto
new weapons in the war against Russia
coming up what the UK donated to
Ukrainian forces
foreign
supreme court has ordered the release of
former prime minister Imran Khan ruling
his arrest was illegal Khan is still in
custody but is able to see some friends
and family his dramatic arrest Tuesday
over allegations of corruption sparked a
wave of violence across the country
there was tension again today between
police and supporters celebrating his
release Khan was ousted as prime
minister just over a year ago and has
been campaigning for early elections
ever since
a rocket has fired from Gaza hitting a
building in Israel and killing one man
it's part of the latest and worse
violence in months between Israel and
Palestinian militants earlier in the day
Israeli airstrikes killed two more
commanders of the Palestinian Islamic
Jihad a group said to be responsible for
many rocket attacks against Israel the
spike in fighting started Tuesday and
has killed more than 25 Palestinians
many civilians and children hundreds of
rockets have been fired upon Israel in
retaliation all while Egypt attempts to
broker a ceasefire
Russia launched a deadly Air Assault on
eastern Ukraine today several places
were targeted including a home in
sloviansk at least one woman was killed
the city just Northwest of bakmut has
been repeatedly targeted by Russian
troops
Ukrainian President Vladimir zielinski
says his soldiers are ready for a fresh
spring offensive but are waiting on
promised reinforcements from NATO today
the UK announced it has donated
long-range cruise missiles to Ukraine
the first country to do so as Crystal
gaman Singh reports it could be a key
piece of Battlefield Equipment
the Storm Shadow missile has armor and
bunker busting capabilities the UK
defense secretary says the long-range
missiles give Ukraine a better chance at
pushing back Russian forces on their
territory we simply will not stand by
while Russia kills civilians we have
seen what ukrainians can do when they
have the right capabilities but Ben
Wallace acknowledged the Storm Shadow
missiles are not in the same league as
what Russia is currently hitting Ukraine
with the newly donated missiles can
travel roughly 250 kilometers where
Russia's caliber cruise missiles for
example can hit targets 2 000 kilometers
away
the grief and horror of those attacks
can be seen across Ukraine the governor
of the zaparita region reported eight
people were injured Thursday including
three ambulance workers responding to
the strikes
how can they make us suffer like this
people have struggled all their life now
they are left with nothing
five months of fighting have leveled
buckmut control of the city means
control of a Supply route to the Eastern
Battlefront both sides claimed they're
making progress albeit slowly
anyone hoping the wait for a
counter-offensive would end after the
long and grueling winter we'll have to
wait a bit longer the Ukrainian
president revealed to the BBC that his
troops are ready but they won't be
pushing ahead until more weapons
including tanks are delivered the spring
offensive may not be getting underway
just yet but a new training mission in
Latvia begins on Monday it's a joint
initiative between Canada and Latvia and
Junior officers will be trained in areas
such as responsibility of battle and
maneuver coordination Canadian Forces
are now in three countries training
ukrainians nithu crystal gomancing in
London thanks Crystal
Wildfire worries ahead how the smoke is
impacting Hospital intake across Canada
as parts of western Canada battle an
early start to the Wildfire season the
Ripple effects have some people turning
to hospitals for help with exposure to
smoke and it's not just those being
forced to flee their homes Catherine
Ward reports
as emergency crews battle blazes out
west doctors manage the Fallout in
emergency rooms we see every year the
Wildfire seasons are becoming a lot
longer and they're becoming a lot more
intense the result more people needing
medical attention because of gases and
particulates being released into the air
and these are a microscopic little
particles that are ingested through the
nose and and through the lungs and can
lead to a wide variety of symptoms in
the general population a health
consideration for people right across
the country according to Angela Yao a
senior scientist at the BC Center for
Disease Control we can travel miles and
miles away from the actual fire and when
it's reached us then it can get pretty
deep into our lungs and cause
inflammation certainly my phone is
ringing for patients who are being
exposed to the poor air quality and
asking what to do doctors say keeping an
eye on the air quality index during Wild
Fire season
conditions are poor keep windows and
doors closed and even think about using
air conditioning that doesn't pull from
the outside experts say it's also
important to plan ahead and prepare an
emergency kit in case you need to leave
or shelter in place essential things for
that kit include some water some food
your medications we often have people
coming into the emergency department in
Yellowknife who have evacuated from
other communities and they left in such
a hurry that they forgot their
medications and to not take chances if
concerning symptoms persist the thought
is that these fine particles that
they're released from the Wildfire smoke
you know especially children can impact
potential lung Health growth secondly
people who have recurrent exposures to
wildfires there's there is some you know
epidemiological evidence to suggest that
there's an increased risk of developing
asthma we need to start paying attention
as a society about you know the
frequency and how intense these fires
are becoming and we need to you know
really get our act together Catherine
Ward Global News Toronto
[Music]
that is global national for this
Thursday night I'm Nita Garcia tonight's
your Canada is point Claire Quebec
thanks for watching Fara Nasser will be
at the anchor desk tomorrow have a great
night
[Music]